all right guys welcome back to the best
business show i'm super excited today's
special episode we have david sacks uh
world renowned entrepreneur investor um
everything from uh founding ceo of
paypal uh founder of yammer uh we're ceo
of zenifitz for a while uh founded craft
ventures uh where i think it's what you
spend most of your time doing uh today
um and just you've got a bucket load of
experience uh both as an investor and a
founder um and uh very excited to have
you here so thank you so much great
thank you for joining us um you're here
in miami because the all-in summit uh i
guess my first question is uh you've got
your three uh maybe knucklehead friends
who uh uh you guys start a podcast and
now it's one of the most popular
podcasts in the world did you expect the
all-in podcast to be uh what it became
no definitely not i mean it's been a
huge surprise to all of us and i mean i
didn't even set out consciously to
create the pod what happened is chamath
and j-cal
started doing the pod and then freeburg
and i were the first two guests and then
i think by the third or fourth show we
did episode with the four of us and the
chemistry felt good so we ended up kind
of that became the foursome
and yeah it turned out to be this sort
of sensation i didn't even realize how
much people were into it till we did
this event it was pretty incredible we
had 700 people come from all over the
world to to be with us wow and at the
event it seemed like there was uh both
what you would expect at a tech
conference of kind of hey tech uh
technology optimism and kind of this
stuff can help uh improve the world but
also at times there was like contentious
debate and respectful debate but uh talk
a little bit about like why is that so
important i guess at an event like the
all-in summit and even on the podcast
sometimes you know you guys go back and
forth and definitely have different
viewpoints on some of these topics yeah
i think one of the things i think one of
the reasons for the success of the pod
is that we're friends um that it's the
conversation is civil but we're able to
disagree with each other and frequently
we do
disagree we have political debates and
they don't necessarily break down into
easy categories um i mean j cal and i
are usually on opposite sides but where
free bergen chamoth will come out will
vary quite a bit depending on the issue
so it's unpredictable but it's a debate
and but it's civil we're all friends
and that's the model you just don't see
anymore if you turn on cable news there
are no debate shows anymore i mean 20
years ago all the political shows were
debates you know
but you don't see that anymore it's
basically people talking to their echo
chamber
and i think
you know seeing the return of that kind
of um civil discourse is important
why did the cable news all become
non-debate or kind of echo chamber based
right like and i think a key piece of
this is like you've been talking about
the same stuff for 30 years right if
people go back and you can read books
you can go look at some of the the
things that um you and many of the
people in the paper mafia wrote even
talks that you gave early on in your
career why has the world changed so much
but many of you have stayed just so
steadfast and like this is our message
it's a good question
it may be some of it has to do with the
economic model of this news media where
they've kind of moved to this subscriber
model and so the goal seems to be to
give subscribers more of what they want
more of what sort of flatters their
prejudices or their preconceptions their
biases not to challenge
you know the world view that the
subscribers already have and i think you
saw this for example with the new york
times and a lot of these traditional
publications were really struggling
until donald trump came along and then
they kind of rebranded themselves as the
resistance and whether you're four
against trump is sort of beside the
point the point is that the media chose
this sort of activist model that was
designed around trying to appeal to a
certain kind of subscriber base
and um and in the process i think they
sort of gave up their objectivity or at
least their pretense of neutrality
um but certainly yeah you just don't see
the type of um debate anymore that you
used to see you know when i grew up uh i
mean gorbadol versus william buckley was
sort of before my time but you had shows
like firing line with pat buchanan
versus michael kinsley uh you had a
mclaughlin group you had like all these
shows where people would debate each
other and it was relatively civil now
you don't have the debate and it's
certainly not civil yeah uh when you
think about something like the all-in
podcast i don't think any of you would
uh position yourself as a journalist but
obviously there's a lot of people who
consume that context they want to learn
they want to actually get information as
to what's happening in current events
how different is that actually than some
of these media companies where people
are you know hiding behind or uh kind of
positioning themselves as journalists
like is it now everyone on the
internet's a content creator or is there
still a big difference in your opinion
well i think we have this epidemic of
fake experts you know people who claim
some sort of expert status but really as
a way to shut down the debate like oh
you don't know what you're talking about
i'm an expert so just listen to me
um i think if you're an entrepreneurial
type of person
that sort of appeal to authority has
never worked you know founders
always start from having an idea that's
either contrarian or no one's really
thought of before and this idea that oh
i need to listen to what somebody else
says automatically um without consulting
you know my own um
my my own ideas uh my own world view
because there's some sort of expert i
think that's never been compelling to
people in our world
and but that's kind of what you get a
lot of it in the traditional media now i
don't purport to be an expert i'm just a
consumer of information but what i try
to do is go out and research the topics
that we're going to talk about on the
pod
and formulate my own view and synthesize
material from people who i find
compelling or convincing and then i
repackage it in my own way and then
um sort of um
you know sort of
talk about that so and then people
either like it or they don't um but but
yeah that's that's what i try to do and
how important is it that you actually
have skin in the game i think another
piece of this is like you know a
journalist or a blogger or whoever uh on
the internet opinion whether it's right
or wrong kind of there's no feedback
loop there's no accountability just move
on to the next you know hot take or
prediction versus the market participant
whether it's an entrepreneur or an
investor uh if you're wrong and you put
money behind it you lose money right and
then there is that kind of feedback loop
and so is that play an important role as
well in terms of the way that you think
about the content that you guys are are
producing yeah certainly when it comes
to all the business topics we do
actually have skin of the game where
participants in the ecosystem we're
discussing business strategies that we
ourselves are implementing and so there
is you know market feedback on that um
and if we're wrong then we will pay a
penalty
you just don't see that you know in the
in general in the news media and there
seems to be no penalty
for being wrong
uh it just seems like we just move on to
the next topic and there's never a
comeuppance for the people who are so
tragically wrong about what the last
issue was
um you know where was the comeuppance
for example for the foreign policy
establishment that got us into the iraq
war and got us into a losing effort in
afghanistan for 20 years i mean these
people are still in the government
there's just no
no heads have rolled even the bosh
withdrawal from afghanistan no heads
rolled for that there's no
accountability
so there's so many issues like that the
the lockdowns that we pursued during
covet
um now everybody i think has sort of
admitted that they're wrong there's a
video going around of bill gates
basically saying they didn't work
so even the people who were advocating
for them at the time now admit they were
just tragically wrong basically crater
our economy
um didn't stop the virus
where's the comeuppance for the people
who promoted those policies i think
there will eventually will be hopefully
at the ballot box but certainly in the
media they're not holding anybody
accountable yeah well and i would even
argue that many of the people in the
media don't believe that they didn't
work right they still would advocate
that they're important and uh uh in some
ways that we should still have some form
of of these things um when you talk
about this like
fake expertise or this appeal to
expertise uh it just makes me think of
the time when fauci was doing an
interview and he basically said like i
represent science right right and and uh
that's one example of many i think in
society but like it is important i think
to have people who are not market
participants commentating et cetera but
it does feel like podcast twitter and
many of these other forms have let the
market participants now have a voice and
in some cases you know if you look at
elon and some of these folks who have
tens of millions of followers on these
platforms they have a bigger voice than
even some of the media companies like i
think i saw um when elon went to go buy
twitter i went and i looked and elon has
double the number of followers on
twitter that the new york times has and
twitter does you know much more revenue
than the new york times does and so like
in some way do you get the new york
times is now a competitor with twitter
and if elon owns twitter like
are you just a billionaire you know are
you employing people at the new york
times as a billionaire to attack other
billionaires and like vice versa like
how do you think about that well i think
that
the traditional media has had a huge
animus towards social networking for
years because social networking has not
only
stolen all these page views and all this
attention and engagement away from them
and and thereby
uh you know turn their analog doll
dollars into digital pennies remember
that that old saying so dramatically
impacted their business model for the
worst but also has disintermediated them
i mean the only time i ever go to the
new york times is if somebody who i like
tweets something that's interesting that
links to a new york times article so
the power and influence of these
publications has been dramatically
reduced by social networking and that's
why you've seen
basically this war on social networking
and the the form it takes is basically
these claims that you know it was
primarily facebook last year uh you know
it creates all these harms on society
and therefore we need to regulate and
restrict and censor them
and
you know it's pretty striking that you
see
publications who
were are supposed to be champions of the
first amendment because that's the
principle on which their whole business
is built now
advocating for
censoring and restricting these
platforms yeah um talk to me about uh
the members of the all-in podcast and
the last thing we'll talk about uh do
you and jason like each other are you
guys actually friends
all right
i think a lot of people think you're
friends but then they listen to the
podcast like man they're always at each
other's throat to some degree um yeah we
also agree on a lot of issues and um you
know the way i i kind of see it so
whenever there's an issue that jason can
see with his own eyes and hear with his
own ears so for example
uh san francisco we agree about like
everything that's gone wrong in san
francisco we probably vote the exact
same way you know in elections and so on
but when it comes to things that are far
away
jason relies i think to a great
extent on the traditional news media for
his views and so
on the pod he's going to represent you
know like the brian steltzer opinion or
something
and so this is why we end up getting in
disputes is i'm like dude you're just
repeating the same [ __ ] narrative
that you know we get in all these other
places i have to correct you on that and
then that starts a debate so we do agree
on a lot but that's where things go off
the rails
and obviously you're incredibly kind to
him the entire time as well um when when
you think about uh so many of the people
that uh you grew up in your career right
as an entrepreneur now as an investor
they've gone on to do amazing things and
and uh some of them are still very
publicly known and um uh even
participating in the podcast all that uh
but many of them also just are busy
building companies and people know about
them but they don't necessarily go in
the media all the time what's your
relationship with like with them i think
a lot of people say like hey there's
this group of folks from the paypal
mafia that are all super super
successful like do you guys have a
secret chat where you're all constantly
talking to each other is it just as
normal friends as anybody else would
have like what does that relationship
look like well there were pre-existing
friendships before the paypal mafia that
brought the team together you know one
people the one misconception about the
paper mafia is people think it was like
some sort of very exclusive club
and the reality is we recruited our
friends because nobody else would work
at the company
this would go back to 1999. it was like
much harder and then 2000 after the
dotcom crash it was much harder to
convince somebody to leave a safe
well-paying job at an investment bank or
management consulting firm or a law firm
to come work at a startup that was still
seen as an incredibly risky thing to do
when i joined paypal
everyone tried to talk me out of it
including you know my from my parents on
down
um if i hadn't known uh peter thiel and
been friends with him i never would have
taken that risk um and so on down the
line so peter recruited the people he
knew from stanford max recruited people
he knew from u of i
so um
yeah i mean so there were a lot of
pre-existing friendships and then the
experience of going through
these paypal wars together
um you know i'd say generally
develop those friendships even more now
it's not like we hang out with each
other all the time and it's not like one
monolithic group but we do tend to see
each other from time to time in various
contexts so yeah catch up and
why is it that you all
were friends before like is it just you
happen to all end up at stanford or u of
i or was there some common thread like
what brought you all together because i
think a lot of people look around at
their friend circle like saying college
and they're like man i don't think elon
musk is hanging out here right i don't
think whatever like what brought you all
together what was like the selection
mechanism that you kind of would
attribute uh how you all ended up
together
well
so max recruited his um engineering
friends at u of i so i think that was
pretty straightforward and then peter
recruited a number of the people he was
friends with and you know peter had
started had founded the stanford view
which is sort of the conservative
libertarian student newspaper on campus
and i had gone on to become an editor of
that paper several years later so that's
how we met
so there was this libertarian strand to
the founding team and
so
we were all and that was sort of like
this contrarian um
you know
libertarians tend to be not just
contrarian but also sort of um free
market
and so there was a certain sense in
which everybody was cut from
uh this sort of uh entrepreneurial cloth
um
now
it's not universally true you know like
uh reid hoffman was not part of the
stanford review in fact he was sort of
on the other extreme he was more liberal
and he still is to this day but he and
peter used to have political debates or
discussions in college and then that's
how reid you know ended up being
recruited by peter so
it's not universally true but there was
something to that that
the founding team were
you know like um
given the sort of the prevailing college
uh the prevailing culture on college
campuses at that time which was sort of
this whole political correctness thing
uh we were rebels against that and i
think that rebel mentality translated
well into becoming founders of
entrepreneurs once we graduated yeah my
last question before some current events
is uh let's say that liber uh you know
libertarian conservative uh viewpoint in
the 90s would you consider yourself a
libertarian a republican how do you kind
of label yourself if you had to put
yourself in a box today and like did
that change over time or has it always
been kind of the same box you would have
put yourself in throughout your life
yeah i guess when i was in college you
sort of figure out where your political
views are and how you would categorize
them and and yeah i would say i was more
on the libertarian end
of the the spectrum you know during like
let's say the reagan era the
um
the the conservative movement was sort
of an uneasy
uh alliance of a few different groups
you had sort of free market types a la
like milton friedman
you had
social conservatives and then you had
sort of anti-communist
uh you know cold warrior types and um
and i guess the group that i
identified myth with the most would have
been more on the free market economic
side but i also agree with kind of the
reaganite approach to peace through
strength but in any event um
and then you know after the cold war
ended i think the political categories
got reshuffled a little bit and um
and so i would say yeah my views today
have have evolved and they're probably a
little bit more in a populist direction
um and we can delve more more into that
yeah explain a little bit more well
so
um
if you look at
what the big political divide is in
america if you actually poll people
about their political views the number
one predictor of where someone's going
to fall in the political spectrum is
whether they have a college degree or
not interesting and so if you actually
look at the views of people who are in
the professional class i.e people have a
college degree
is radically different than the views by
and large of the working class which is
people with just say a high school
education
and that is the fundamental
division in this country now it's not
universally true there are plenty of
people with a college degree like me who
have more let's say working class views
and then vice versa so but by and large
that's the division and there's a whole
host of issues
where uh the the professional class is
very much out of touch with what the
working class thinks and
the uh the uh political scientists who
actually i think has developed this the
most is a guy named roy tashira
who everyone should really check out his
sub stack if you're interested in this
but he's been doing work over the last
couple of years sort of documenting this
and showing the polling and so forth
he remember he is the author back in the
early 2000 like 2002 of a book called
the coming or democratic majority maybe
emerging democratic majority in which he
predicted
that demographic trends would result in
the election of democratic presidents as
far as the eye could see
and he was then pretty much considered a
prophet because obama then got elected
in 2008 building the type of coalition
that tashira describes in his book
interesting um so sincerely but lately
over the last couple of years and
tashira is a democrat wants democrats to
win he's been warning the party you have
gotten way too far left
on sociocultural issues like for example
censorship but as one of many
um and the reason is because you're
stopping a working-class party you are
now a professional class party you cater
to the views
of uh of professional elites
uh and
but but but but you're speaking to
yourself you're speaking increasingly to
an echo chamber because you are out of
touch with
the rest of the country and so for
example he very much uh predicted
something like the election of uh glen
yunken in virginia remember
this is a state that is pretty much a
blue state now virginia
uh biden won the state by 10 points in
2020 and one year later youngkin wins by
two or three points so 12 13 point swing
why on issues like schools you know crt
uh you know wanting to provide uh
putting the parents back in charge
and providing kids with a high quality
non-ideological
education you know this is the type of
issue that really
sets off most americans but
uh you know the elites the professional
class is deeply invested in this idea of
crt doesn't take like one example where
there's like a very big class divide on
that issue
so tushira has been warning about the
way in which the democratic party he
calls it professional class hegemony has
been co-opted by this professional class
now what's happening in the republican
party is really interesting the
republican party is in the process of
transforming itself into a working-class
party very different than
uh what it historically been
historically republican party was more
like a chamber of commerce type of party
now what you see
uh with this more populist
uh edge to it is it's trying to appeal
to the working class now a lot of people
would say it's fake you know it's not
real
but that's kind of what's in the process
of happening um now you know my theory
about why there is so much contention
and divisiveness in the country what we
all feel the strife is because
if you look at just numbers
30 something like 37 of the country has
a college degree it's professional class
63 is working class okay so
the working class has the numbers in a
democracy their views should prevail yes
and yet the elites
run every institution from the prestige
media
to hollywood to wall street to the
fortune 500 to the foundations the
non-profits the think tanks the big you
know even the big funds
obviously those are all run by people
with college degrees and so the
professional class hegemony that tuchera
talks about the democratic party also
exists across the board in all these
institutions and so by and large you
have this phenomenon of institutions in
this country being out of step with what
most people believe and trying to push
an agenda on them that the rest of the
country doesn't support that is finally
the divide and the friction in this
country
now
you
i think what i've described is just
objectively the case of what's going on
you could still be a member of the
professional class and still think it's
a good thing
that the fortune 500 is pushing will
capitalism or twitter is pushing for
censorship of ideas they don't like and
so on and they do but i think
fundamentally this is the tension is
that
the leadership of the country not just
the political leadership in washington
but really much more deeply across the
board of all of our institutions they
have views that are out of step with
most of the country and i think how we
resolve that
tension
is the that's the political issue of our
time yeah one of the things that as
you're talking immediately jumps to mind
is uh you've probably seen the the
phrase the meme of uh good times create
uh weak man weak men create bad times
right bad times great uh strongmen and
when i think about this there is this
like bifurcation i think economically as
well where we have a country with 45 of
americans have no investable assets
inflation obviously right now it's at a
40-year
high um and if you were to talk to that
professional class i think most of the
people would say hey the last 10 15
years have been amazing right pretty
much since the global financial crisis
like everyone's gotten richer and richer
but at the same time what we've actually
seen is that that working class hasn't
kind of been along for that ride in the
same way and really they've actually
gone the opposite direction so you kind
of get this widening divide how much of
the economic situation plays into some
of these thought processes and the
transitions between the way that the uh
political you know kind of parties are
actually transitioning is that a fair
way yeah i think
it plays into it hugely and i think one
of the big issues the last 20 years is
the way that our trade policy basically
hollowed out the industrial base of the
country um you know this is the the
phenomenon of you know we brought china
into the wto and we gave them
you know permanent you know basically
mfn status
and as a result we exported millions and
millions of sort of middle-class
working-class jobs where people made
things with their hands as opposed to
knowledge worker type jobs overseas to
china and so forth that created enormous
discontent in the country
and that basically is one of the main
reasons why trump got elected in 2016.
remember the the democrats thought they
had this what they call the blue the
blue wall yeah in the midwest the
industrial midwest the the rust belt
and
fell apart it fell apart trump
absolutely shattered that wall
and one of the main ways he did it was
appealing to the fact that
really bipartisan trade policy would
last 20 years destroyed
these factory towns all over the midwest
now
i think that
when you lose an election to a total
political novice and outsider who has so
many characteristics that you would
think would be disqualifying that the
elite
would basically start having second
thoughts and asking itself tougher
questions about the way they've been
ruling the country
and yet they haven't i mean the reaction
to 2016 basically was this
hysteria that this tds and again
i'm not like
in saying this trying to advocate for
trump or something i'm just advocating
for when you lose an election
you need to have some
sense of introspection and asking
why that happened and how your policies
might have contributed to it i mean the
other big issue that trump ran on were
all these stupid wars that america has
gotten itself into over the last 20
years and remember this was a critique
as much of the republican party as the
democratic party remember when trump
said no more bushes what he meant was no
more stupid wars in the middle east we
got ourselves
into
iraq
afghanistan syria libya we spent over
six trillion dollars on nation building
in the middle east and what do we have
to show for it nothing they just hate us
even more the problem is worse than all
these countries you know um afghanistan
is back in the hands of the taliban
iraq is basically now an iranian proxy
state libya is in chaos and civil war
syria assad's still running it um so all
these efforts were for naught and but i
think they along with our trade policy
created tremendous discontent in the
country imagine if we had spent that six
trillion dollars back here at home
fixing some of the problems you're
talking about maybe we wouldn't be at
each other's throats quite so much as we
are today
so
you had these huge issues um in the
country over which discontent was
bubbling over
and
you know instead of basically holding
itself accountable the elites of the
country and it's really again bipartisan
police who set these policies for two
decades rather than having any
introspection they would blame they
blamed the election on like russian
disinformation that somehow the russians
caused trump to be elected
you know or somehow the country was shot
through with white supremacy that was
the reason trump got elected they never
were willing to look in the mirror and
understand the real causes and what's
happened since 2016 is that
these mythologies have really only grown
and so
this is now what basically somehow has
morphed into this uh this censorship
crusade where you know it started with
this
again this idea that somehow the
russians were responsible for trump's
election rather than these deep-seated
issues in the country
and that has now blossomed and grown
into this full-fledged
this sort of content moderation movement
in which we're going to take down and
censor anything we consider to be
disinformation which is basically
anything that the people the elites
running twitter think is is an idea they
disagree with you you probably didn't
see it yet because it happened right
before we get started this conversation
but uh there's now a report out that
says the disinformation board is being
paused and uh and may actually be uh
permanently disbanded and this is in the
homeland security department correct and
and so i think a huge piece of this what
like to me um and i'd love to get your
reaction to this is it feels like
there's a sentiment shift under underway
and part of the sentiment shift is um
free speech capitalism and kind of the
building uh movement is coming back and
i think you see this with you know jeff
bezos all of a sudden now he's tweeting
and he's going pretty hard at the
present united states and he kind of to
me was like michael jordan hey
republicans and democrats both buy goods
and you know
my political views aren't nearly as
important too yeah right
and and so when you kind of think about
this it does feel like um you know one
of the worst nightmares for politicians
is to have the best entrepreneurs of our
generation armed with twitter accounts
willing to speak their mind and to your
point earlier about kind of the media it
used to be you had to go through the
media to to get your voice heard now if
you can go directly to the people
it feels like sentiment will shift it's
almost like a pendulum it's swung too
far to the the kind of woke capital and
a lot of those things and now it's
coming back and again i don't think many
people would advocate like let's swing
to the other extreme right but more of
this centrist view of hey businesses are
put on you know in existence to solve
problems right like that's actually
probably a pretty important part of the
united states right look i absolutely
agree that the whole country is red
pilling right now because i think that
the the censorship has gone way too far
the um the way that the the
far left sort of progressive left has
hijacked the bite administration people
thought they were voting for some sort
of centrism instead we've gotten this
like very um far-left agenda
and then you have again you have this um
this is this sort of cancel culture that
people are really reacting to that
they're sick of but you're right so many
people are red pilling you've got jeff
bezos basically attacking the
administration elon's become so much
more political on twitter he basically
said at all in summit the other day that
he's going to vote republican he's never
voted republican before but he's doing
it he's only voted democratic because he
said the democratic party's been
hijacked by a bunch of radicals um
you've got you know like guys like rogan
um
who was a bernie sanders supporter but
you know he's been read out of the
democratic party because he is willing
to interview people
who have a differing view on vaccines
for example that's why
they read him out and all of a sudden he
was being accused of racism and so forth
so
it's that you have this very intolerant
movement on the far left that keeps
basically kicking people out i don't
know how they're going to win many
elections with this philosophy they have
but they're absolutely red pilling you
know huge numbers of people now the
republicans could still blow this like
you said they could go too far but yeah
absolutely there's a huge backlash
underway yeah the last thing i want to
talk about from a political standpoint
is uh also uh there's this like um label
now as long as you say something is
right wing you basically get to uh
excuse the attack right oh we have to
fear the the right wing attack and and i
don't think anyone thinks that
right-wing extremism is any better than
left-wing extremism right it's kind of
again this kind of centuries view how do
you think about uh what i would almost
argue as either propaganda or marketing
coming from these labels like is this
something that's always existed in you
know public discourse and and in the
united states or is this definitely
social media kind of exasperating it and
it's becoming more obvious well so we
had a panel at the allen summit that i
moderated with glenn greenwald and matt
taibbi and it was about this very topic
where in the grew out of a remark that
jason
had made on our pod that that he was
actually having trouble recruiting
left-wing people to speak because they
would they saw all these right-wingers
on the program right-wingers like um
glenn greenwald and matt taibbi and i
was kind of laughing at this saying
you don't know who these guys are you
know glenn greenwald broke the snowden
story he's been a consistent critic of
the surveillance state and the way it
infringes our civil liberties
historically that was always a liberal
position matt taibi was the political
writer at rolling stone who is basically
a left-wing firebrand who back in 2009
was writing why has no one gone to jail
for the you know global financial crisis
that was caused by all these mortgage
scams you know he basically laid some of
the intellectual groundwork for the
bernie sanders movement the occupy wall
street movement and somehow he is now
this like far right winger why because
he doesn't agree with the narrative
orthodoxy if you're willing to dissent
in any way with whatever the current
thing is today then you get brandon's
being a far right person dave rubin i
think is another one like this right he
was a democrat who eventually just
transitioned over and said i don't agree
with this anymore if you disagree with
whatever the current orthodoxy is you
get labels being this like far-right
lunatic um you know rogan's in that camp
too broken it's just an independent
curious guy but again if you dare to
have a thought that's unconventional or
just interview the wrong person
then you're branded this way and look
the common denominator is that
th these people on this sort of far left
fringe but and it is a fringe but they
hold tremendous institutional power
because the dynamic we were talking
about they want to end the debate
they do not want to have a debate i
think their views are very unpopular in
the country and that's why so they would
rather censor the debate they want to
have the right to declare that the other
side is engaged in disinformation they
don't want to just have a debate where
they say no listen i think you're wrong
i think you're an idiot here's why here
are the receipts here's a bunch of facts
they don't want to have that kind of
debate they basically want the power to
say oh that other side is disinformation
we know the truth
from on high and so we are basically
gonna shut down the debate and say we
can't have this discussion anymore and
you know these labels are another way of
doing it it's a course of tactic to
basically
try and punish people
by ostracizing them
in order to shut down the debate and i
think you always have to ask yourself
the question
when someone is trying to use tactics to
end the debate why are they doing that
you know if they can win the debate if
they have intellectual confidence why
don't they just have the debate
how much of this falls back on this idea
of uh there's a critical thinking crisis
in america like people literally don't
know how to do critical thinking they
don't know how to do the introspection
is it rooted in our education system is
just the factory and just hey go through
get the stamp and move on uh or is it no
people actually have these skill sets
they could be a first principles thinker
they could be a critical thinker uh but
they're choosing not to because they've
already done the exercise and realized
that they don't have the kind of
intellectual you know accuracy to stand
on i think i think the critical thinking
problem is real and i think it stems
from the education system and the
reality is we've indulged too much of
this nonsense that if you are required
to encounter if you you don't like
that's somehow a threat to your safety
you know that's your psychological
safety if you have your mind expanded by
a view that you
initially
were surprised by or disagreed with that
is now forbidden and you know we've seen
professors all over the country
basically get
punished
um
you know suspend and so forth or they
you know
they um
you know they have their their uh podium
taken away because they've got a few
students in the class who don't like
some view they heard and then they
complain the administration about it and
they say that their safety is being
threatened
look we heard the same thing we hear the
same thing on social media with the
rogan debate you know that
spotify said that well
fortunately they didn't kick rogan off
but they said that
you know we were very concerned about
user safety as if joe rogan was somehow
you know
somehow breaking into people's living
rooms or something and turning on their
sound system to his podcast and making
them listen and and even the act of
listening would somehow endanger them
you know the whole idea is silly
uh but this is a type of language that
is used again to silence the debate they
want to end the debate that's the point
of it joe rogan is a guy who smokes weed
and asks people questions which makes
him the most dangerous man in america
right right um let's talk about uh the
market economics and and uh some of
what's going on in uh venture capital um
40-year high inflation i think right now
the federal reserve is probably the most
important institution when it comes to
markets and they've kind of in control
it seems like over the last decade or so
it's just whatever the fed tells you to
do do they tell you to go long and
they're going to pump asset prices like
do it and shut up if they say hey we're
going to tighten just basically get out
of the market or go short and let them
do their thing uh is that healthy for
markets to have the federal reserve
basically being the driver of good times
and bad times if the federal reserve did
a better job maybe it'd be okay but i
think they've done a horrible job in
recent years and um so first of all you
had
the the i mean does anyone at this point
doubt that the reaction to kovid was
more damaging to the country than covet
itself
both economically and also in terms of
the
restrictions that were imposed
i think there's abundant evidence now
for example we talked about the lockdown
front that they just didn't work they
didn't stop the virus they didn't do
anything except plunge us into a very
deep recession and then what did the
government do in reaction to that they
printed 10 trillion dollars
and so they flooded the zone with money
over the past few years and then that
eventually led to an inflation spike
last summer
the fed in reaction to that i remember
the 5.1 percent inflation print last
summer everyone was stunned by it
because we've gone for years and years
with very low inflation and the talk was
always about whether we're in a
deflationary spiral and that kind of
stuff
and but the fed said that it was
transitory they didn't react to it
instead they kept interest rates low and
they kept qe going
qe didn't stop till the end of q1 we
were still the fed was intervening in
capital markets to buy bonds to
artificially keep the price down as soon
as we got that 5.1
print they should have stopped the qe
right away maybe take a little bit of
time to assess whether you're going to
raise rates but the qe why would you do
that you know we clearly didn't need qe
at that point i think it got to the
point if i remember the data correctly
at one point the federal reserve via all
of these actions owned like one in four
residential mortgages in america but i
mean just like crazy crazy stats right
and if that's not the exact same it's
directionally just such a ridiculous
thing that uh you had a persistent buyer
in the market and they weren't going to
stop until you know eventually we get
over eight percent and then well maybe
we should stop now right exactly so
because the fed waited so long to react
to inflation it got worse for now it
went like 8.3 or whatever it'll come
down just by virtue of lapping
last year's comp
on a year-over-year basis but it's still
going to be there
um
but they reacted way too slowly and now
the fear i think is you know powell just
said a couple weeks ago that he doesn't
see a risk of recession on the horizon
i'm like what are you smoking you know
pal i mean do they actually believe what
they're saying i don't know but you know
from where i'm sitting in silicon valley
we're we're already in a recession you
know and people are starting to act like
that
and so i think we're headed for now for
you know pretty serious
um recession
by virtue of the fact that again the fed
left the punch ball out way too long and
then yanked it back so violently
that it's
causing the real economy now to um to
convulse and contract
um
so yeah i think that you know the
problem is that the fed just has gotten
all these decisions wrong and look the
federal government hasn't been much
better i mean
it was about this time a year ago when
the the
blind administration on straight party
line vote passed that last two trillion
dollars of covet reliefs that slash
stimulus the american rescue plan
and it was totally unnecessary i mean
the economy was already coming back
strongly from covid you had um you know
famed investors like stanley
druckenmiller saying look retail is
already 15 above trend meaning the
consumer is fully back and spending
their money you don't need to pump and
you had democratic economists like larry
summers warning them don't do it this
poses a huge risk of inflation
and they said larry summers you're crazy
didn't listen they you know and that was
basically the final straw that broke the
camel's back to be sure this is what
basis has been basically yeah exactly
and bezos is right
um
so it's ridiculous to somehow now blame
um this inflation on putin you know like
the this is the putin price hike i don't
think anyone's buying it but it's not
because of something putin's doing over
in eastern europe it's because the fed
and congress the administration pumped
10 trillion now this problem started
before biden to be sure it's a
bipartisan problem but
that last 2 trillion and the fed's
actions last year
magnified this problem made it much
worse and as a result you're going to
get a much more severe correction to the
to what's happened in the form of a
deeper recession it brings a good
question of how independent is the
federal reserve and i think if you look
backwards we had trump tweeting at them
about you know devouting the currency we
obviously saw last summer they continued
this and how much of that was
politically motivated versus you know
economic analysis and then also going
into the midterm elections are the
political class going to be applying
pressure to
increase interest rates cut interest
rates you know what can they do to kind
of get a soft landing going into this
midterm election like how independent do
you think that organization is at this
point you know it's hard for me to know
i don't really have insight on like how
the inner workings work um the thing
that just strikes me is that they seem
very out of touch and
you know it's it's like i don't know i
don't have access to the data they have
access to but i have access to
sentiment
and i feel like the sentiment that i
come in contact with and for my opinions
based on somehow it seems more reliable
than whatever they're looking at you
know well this begs a really important
question so we've
ad nauseam over the last year looked at
all of the cpi data and uh things like
you know uh take a rent index right
there's cpi rent index and it was
showing that it was up two three four
percent year over year but zillow was at
nine or ten percent apartment.com was up
you know 13 14
and so we started looking we're like
well zillow's indexing methodology they
have access to you know 100 million data
points or whatever in real time and
they're watching around the country as
the stuff is moving versus the
methodology for the cpi is like they
basically call like 8 000 people a month
and say hey what's your rent right
uh and then we saw the tweet from jack
dorsey a couple months ago where he
basically said you know hey high
inflation is here or hyperinflation will
happen or whatever language he used
people got very worked up about but if
you think of a company like square like
there's a strong argument that square
has better data than the us government
when measuring things like inflation
because he not only has the consumer
purchasing behavior but he also has
payroll data he's got point of sale
system data et cetera like is there an
argument for us to take the data
methodology and the analysis out of the
hands of the government and have these
private companies either open source
their data or somehow you know put a
helping hand in or
are we okay still having you know bureau
of labor statistics have people go to
the grocery store with a pad and paper
or a tablet and like manually input the
prices
i mean it's a good point you're right
that jack as the leader of square must
have excellent data based on consumer
purchases but i would assume though that
the fed has access to very similar data
so i think the issue was
that they saw inflation as transitory
and that was the official party line
that we heard starting last summer
and it wasn't just the fact it was also
you know yella and the administration
basically saying it they were all out
there with this line you i never heard
the word transitory used so much until
last year
um
and then it took him they never got
religion about the nature of the problem
till the end of the year so i don't the
question is like what was their basis
for believing it would be transitory as
a because that delayed their that was
their excuse for delaying the reaction
and so we needed this medicine that
they're doing now but if the medicine
could have been delivered more gradually
sooner then
you it would have been
the the asset bubble that we had
wouldn't have grown so much so remember
the frothiest time that i can remember
in venture capital
since basically 1999
was the second half of
of uh last year
really of 2021
and that's when we saw like for example
all the sas valuations go up to 100
times arr and so forth
and i mean everybody will basically tell
you that is that second half of last
year was like it was incredibly frothy
paced deployment went really high for
all venture funds valuations were really
high round sizes were really high look
if you're a founder was a fantastic time
to raise but imagine if the fed
had simply taken the position in the
summer of last year
that
not immediately dismissing this
inflation report and saying okay wait a
second this is something to be concerned
about we're going to
wait and see what happens on interest
rates but we're going to pause qe
i don't think we would have had this
like huge asset bubble in the second
half last year and therefore we wouldn't
have the stock market crash that we've
now had over the last few months and
again i think this is the beginning of
something of a basically a recession
because there are going to be more shoes
to drop right this is the way it works
as these things cascade out you can have
you know chamoth had a stat which he
read on the pod 14 of global wealth has
been wiped out already this year from
the stock market crashed 14
you know the the gfc the global
financial crisis in 2008 was only 18
and that was massive right so that gives
you some idea of how much wealth has
been vaporized and you know my view on
it is when that much wealth gets
vaporized so quickly that must have
downstream consequences in the economy
yeah um i'm going to read you a stat i
didn't know this uh this is a wall
street journal uh article that came out
may 10th and uh there's a woman rachel
wolf who went and she looked she said
how do they calculate the inflation and
so uh your comment about i would assume
they have the same data i assume that as
well uh there's 477 government workers
that literally every morning get a print
out that says go to x grocery store and
go get the you know tomato soup with low
sodium and there's in some cases eight
nine ten eleven page documents to make
sure that the soup that you pick up and
make sure it's the right low sodium soup
the right brand all the stuff and then
you put it into a tablet and they
literally go all around the country and
do this well i i i can save them a lot
of time we have a portfolio company
called date assembly
and literally it does this in an
automated way where if you want to know
like the prices of
milk or bread grocery prices in any like
grocery store in the country you just go
online and you can see it so i don't
know why they're not using data assembly
a lot of time you get them more than 400
data points too
um but beyond that i mean why not look
at like credit card like card
associations go talk to visa mastercard
get some sort of data feed from them and
there there are definitely data services
that provide that yeah that's nutty that
they're still doing that in the pencil
and paperwork when i read the article
twice because i was like this literally
can't be true but um pretty incredible
uh let's talk about bitcoin bitcoin's a
very interesting asset i think in that
there's people who make the argument
it's the most macro asset out there it's
kind of the free market um there's
people who would argue that it's an
inflation hedge and it served as a great
inflation edge because up hundreds of
percent since the start of the pandemic
uh but it's down you know 50 plus
percent over the last couple of months
like
what are your views on bitcoin and how
do you think of that asset given kind of
the macro backdrop
well the thing that's interesting about
bitcoin i've been interested in bitcoin
since i think i first bought it in
2012 maybe okay and uh we we invested in
a number of we're not a crypto investor
but we did um express
uh a thesis back in 2017 2018 that we
thought that crypto
would graduate from being into being a
institutional asset class from being
really more of a consumer retail
phenomenon and so we ended up investing
in institutional custody through a
company called bitco and we also
invested in multi we're the seed
investor multi-coin capital which was a
crypto focused hedge fund we basically
believe that you know that as crypto
matured into an asset class you would
need specialized fund managers of which
we were not really i'm a sass investor
so but i'm like but let's invest in
these guys because they're focused on
the problem
so we expressed the number of these
views and it generally has worked out
very well for us um
but any event so i've been interested in
bitcoin for a while and i think the
transformational part of bitcoin is this
idea that we could have non-fiat money
right we just as we're talking about
with the fed um there is a huge risk of
currency debasement when the government
is in control and particularly when you
have the world's reserve currency
there's just such an enormous temptation
to print money to finance your budget
and to rack up loans that become
unpayable we're at what like 130
of gdp now we own we owe so we owe an
amount of money greater than the size of
our entire economy or our economic
output that sounds very hard to repay to
me
so the temptation will eventually be to
monetize the debt away basically to
debase the currency to pay for this debt
that's always been a risk throughout
history and um
now what bitcoin offers is
a different
kind of currency where it's not backed
by a government it's backed by math it's
backed by encryption and so you don't
have to trust the government
uh that there will only be 21 million
bitcoin it's in the it's in the code
and so you just have to trust that
that the um that bitcoin effectively
won't be cracked you know you just have
to believe
that the system is secure
and i think a lot of people might over
time
gradually think that's a better form of
money yeah
and paypal did you guys start out trying
to build kind of a separate currency
like a new currency or did you always
want to go after uh kind of more of the
the payment system
yeah so we was funny back in 1999 we had
this t-shirt that had the paypal logo on
and it said paypal the new world
currency but what we really meant we
were very much bootstrapped on top of
dollars and there were at that time
rival currencies there was one called
beans one called fluz or whatever like
whoopi uh goldberg was supposed to
anyway
these companies have all died no one
remembers them anymore but we competed
against them in the late 90s and the way
that we won is we were like look we
don't need another currency we have the
dollar the dollar is the world's reserve
currency we just need to make it more
accessible
and so what we meant by the world the
new world currency is creating a dollar
based system that was accessible
anywhere in the world online
and you know one of the things we did
very early on was um
was uh open the site up to other we
internationalized and so people could
basically start moving their net worth
into usd kind of the way that they move
their net worth into bitcoin today um
so but there were some similarities to
the the bitcoin vision you know elon
always called um paypal the database of
money that we're trying to create this
thing you know because if you could get
all the money into one database
then me transferring you money would
just be moving you know electrons around
or what you know um it's be ledger
entries in a database and you could do
it instantly and basically costlessly
uh
that basically describes the blockchain
you know that's basically what the
blockchain is right except it's not a
centralized database of money it's a
decentralized database of money so it's
interesting the way that some of these
ideas have played out but in a different
way than we could have anticipated yeah
peter thiel has told the story where i
guess some of the folks from paypal went
to antigua i believe it is uh and there
was some sort of like encryption and uh
money conference uh and his thought
process is that uh satoshi must have
been there uh one did you go to the
conference and two any uh any thoughts
in terms of that theory yeah i wasn't so
i wasn't at that one i think at that
conference the state of the art in this
crypto world uh was sort of e-gold
and the idea i guess was that you would
get
the certificates that were renewable for
gold and you could move them around
online
and you know the paypal was was sort of
a reaction against that saying no these
systems are too complicated they don't
really make sense again like dollars
worked just fine
uh we weren't trying to upend the
currency itself we're just trying to
make it more convenient
but yeah it's um it's interesting how
there are these predecessors to bitcoin
yeah well i think it's one of the key
pieces right like there's 40 years of r
d that went into the creation of bitcoin
so people always say oh the first one
never works and you know they always
jump to the aols or the the myspaces but
you know it's probably i don't know the
15th or 20th version it seems to seems
to be working um two other questions
around bitcoin i guess one is like do
you think it could rise to become the
global reserve currency and whether
that's you know 500 even 500 years from
now like is the expectation that there
would be decentralized money as the the
core unit of account and kind of store
value globally or do you think that
we'll just get more and more
fragmentation and the fiat currencies
that'll be decentralized uh you know
currency like bitcoin maybe there's even
these private currencies that some of
these companies have tried to create
like how do you think this plays out
it's hard to know i mean biology's got
this framework where there's basically
only three currencies that have scale um
one is the usd sort of
the usd american empire then there's um
china the renminbi
uh and then there's bitcoin in the in
sort of crypto world and he thinks those
are the only three currencies that can
get to sufficient scale to be some sort
of world reserve currency
um i don't know what happens i mean i
think that i think the question is can
you get to something where bitcoin is
widely used without there being like
basically a us dollar collapse or
something catastrophic happening
uh i don't know the answer to that i
think there are sort of
middle scenarios where
um
you know if you were in a country that
had uh
that with like a totalitarian government
or something like that or to export
controls or was extremely repressive
or is being invaded going through a war
you'd want to move as much your net
worth into bitcoin as you could despite
the price volatility because it's
portable you could take it with you
um so in that you know it's the new
diamonds new gold bars whatever so
there's sort of that store value
argument even short of it being a fiat
currency
um but i think it's i think it's
interesting you know um
it's what we're talking about i i didn't
coin this phrase but the separation of
money and state you know we and if that
happens that would be as big an event as
a separation of church and state you
know the church of state used to be
intrinsically linked and combined you
couldn't really think about the two
without them being together now we think
about them being
separate i think money and state is kind
of like that we can't really think
of money without the state but bitcoin
it's sort of this like sci-fi future
where you could maybe have these two
things uh decoupled
um
you know i don't know how long that
takes i don't you know it and it's also
it's very hard to know like what price
you should put on that you know which is
why i don't like actively speculate on
it because um i just don't know what the
price level should be yeah
do you uh still
buy bitcoin like over time just as like
hey i'm just dollar cost averaging or is
this something where hey i bought some
early on that's what i got and you know
i'm gonna go focus on sas investing or
like how do you think about it yeah so i
have a position in it and my view is
kind of to set it and forget it i've
seen so many ups and downs at this point
that i'm just like look i'm gonna put
this amount of money in bitcoin and it's
some percentage of my net worth i'm just
gonna leave it alone and maybe it'll be
worth nothing but maybe this will become
new money over the next 20 years and in
which case i'll feel really stupid if i
didn't buy in a much earlier stage so
i i've kind of got like a little piece
there and just i just leave it alone and
don't try to figure out like these price
moves last thing on bitcoin is um
there's a very large portion of people
in the bitcoin crypto world that are
bitcoin maximalists and so they believe
hey bitcoin is the only thing everything
else is a [ __ ] coin it's all going to
zero uh i don't think you're in that
category given some of the investment
center that you've made
what is your argument for or against
kind of that maximalistic view when it
comes to something like money is it
something that you understand but you're
like hey i'm an investor and i want to
go also find productive assets is it
something you're like i don't understand
you know that view of the world just
talk to me about that
yeah i mean i wouldn't say i'm a
maximalist um i think that the case for
bitcoin is probably the strongest of all
the cryptos and the price and relative
stability reflects that but um
look you have
in the process of creating bitcoin you
have these new other new technologies
arise like the blockchain itself and why
can you use that to support other
you know innovations and so the most
obvious one being you know the idea of a
smart contract platform
and so now you have kind of these other
cryptos that function as gas
to basically buy computing power on a
smart contract platform like you know
like ethereum like solana
that's the space and then there's all
the various applications that
potentially could be run on a blockchain
which mainly you've seen in terms of
ones that have scale it's mostly just
defy you know it's um
mostly financial contracts of various
kinds and financial speculation um i
think what remains
to be seen is
what is the breadth of the applications
that can ultimately be built on top of
blockchains but i think
part of in in the exuberance over these
types of platforms i think there's like
too many things that actually don't
really make a lot of sense where no
you're just better off using a
centralized database
um so the breadth still remains to be
seen but i think what's interesting is
just the
financial contracts the settlement
system the way that you could do
derivatives things like that
it's so much more transparent than what
you could get on wall street where
they're giving you these like otc
derivatives where you don't really
understand what they are at least
with the blockchain with default you can
inspect the code so it does seem like a
better way to do
trading
um and we'll see where it evolves to um
from here
uh but i guess the thing i'm not totally
sure about is the range of applications
that are ultimately gonna emerge yeah it
feels like obviously a blockchain in
terms of what bitcoin is builds on top
of it's all about decentralization and
security right and like one big question
that seems to be unanswered is okay if
there is a separation of money in states
it's probably pretty important to have
decentralization and security against
nation state level attack
what other applications do you need that
level of security and maybe there are
some maybe there aren't uh but there's a
trade-off right performance versus the
security to some degree and uh one of
the things that i
see young founders especially just over
and over and over again uh learning is
like hey i want high performance if you
want high performance like there's a
reason why amazon is a centralized
hierarchical company right they are
incredibly efficient and centralization
isn't good or bad it's just what are you
optimizing for and i think that's kind
of what you're talking about here of
like yeah sure maybe there's some
transparency stuff or whatever but if
you want a high performance thing like
centralization has been the key to
building you know products pretty much
for the last you know couple centuries
right yeah i agree with that that's
that's a big question and people talk
about we need to run social networks on
the blockchain it's kind of like why
although you know censorship does
provide an argument for it but
um yeah i i'm not sure exactly
how
wide the number of applications is the
the issue with bitcoin maximus is they
believe there's precisely one
application to be run on top of
blockchains which is just you know
bitcoin which is money although i guess
they do believe in layer we've made a
number of layer two investments you've
made other bitcoins yeah i mean yeah
yeah so lightning labs for example so
yeah i guess the the just to give the
maximus argument it's due it would just
be that everything will be built on top
of bitcoin and so it's not to say there
won't be other things but they've got
the lightning labs just layer two we
were a c investor in lightning last
month lightning labs i think you guys
did voltage as well right in terms of
lightning nodes um and you know one of
the things that i talked to a lot of
folks in bitcoin community about is like
look uh lightning labs just recently put
out a new um uh proposal for uh this
tarot protocol which is kind of like a
layer three which would allow for
multi-asset issuance on top of the
lightning network and so in some way to
your point right it's not so much like
hey none of these use cases are
available it's just they're not being
built on top of a decentralized you know
thing like bitcoin right um and so we'll
see how it plays out yeah i want to talk
about market conditions right now and
that you you recently put out about an
hour long presentation which uh i think
kudos to you guys for just one calling
all of your founders together and kind
of stated the union hey here's how these
market things play out here's what you
need to do but then going ahead and
publishing it
it seems like things are
bad already
you do you feel like they can get worse
in terms of public markets going down
founders starting to feel the pain over
the next you know six 12 months in the
private market like what's kind of your
general sentiment right now in terms of
like how bad this could get uh from uh
from a reaction to the fed's you know
actions etc right well i think there's
still potentially more shoes to drop um
so i think the most important thing to
realize about the stock market crash
that has already occurred is that it's
been primarily because of multiple
contraction
and so if you look at
multiples like for example in sas
companies which is where we invest
his the current multiple is about 5.6
times arr or next 12 months if you go
back uh about five years that's what it
was so
but
during this sort of hyperinflationary
bubbly period during covet where the fed
congress printed a lot of money
that multiple got all the way up to 15
times and if you were a high growth sas
company which meant basically 40 growth
as opposed to 20 for the average you got
up to 35 times
and that 35 number has gone all the way
down to eight so the high growth has
gone down from 35 times to eight times
and the mean has gone down from 15 to
5.6 so that's mostly been
multiple contraction and the reason is
it's been essentially mean reversion
it's just going back to the way things
used to be before we had 10 trillion
dollars pumped into the system
and this is the thing i think a lot of
founders may not understand is that
you'll hear them say things like well
you always need to get through this
period and then things will go back to
normal so i know you don't understand
this may be the normal period the last
two years were the abnormality that's
basically we all got gaslit by the fed
into thinking we'd have
these conditions of zero interest rates
and tons of liquidity sloshing around
the system and that caused prices to go
through the roof of all financial assets
but especially growth stocks and now
things have returned to earth a little
bit so there's a number of different
groups that are affected by this let's
take uh maybe investors first so if
you're a venture capitalist you're
investing at companies at 15 to 35 times
multiples and now that multiples
contract do you just
hold like do you have any other thing
that you can do do you dollar cost
average uh down if there's down rounds
like how do you guys think about
in the investor seat as this is
occurring do you change anything about
the strategy well i think prices in the
public markets are actually getting
cheap enough for a number of good
companies that it is a buying
opportunity it's just that most people
don't have liquidity to buy because they
just see in their portfolio again
50
this is always the tough part by the way
of you know the buffett aphorism about
be greedy when others are fearful and be
fearful and others are greedy the
problem is no one has any money by the
time that by the time except for him
he's got 130 billion dollars at the
moments where you should be greedy your
portfolio is down 50 so it's hard to
you know double down
uh but look i think there are some
buying opportunities now in the public
market it's not to say that it can't
keep going down for reasons we can
discuss in a second but some of these
companies are starting to look pretty
attractive and is there like a framework
so one of the companies that uh i know
because we were an investor in it and
still have a little bit of public stock
is coinbase and at one point i think it
was trading at like one times basically
revenue uh plus their cash right so uh
you look at something like that and
you're like man
you know maybe it could go down more but
like that sounds like a pretty good you
know multiple based on historical comps
like do you have some framework where
you're like okay with a company that has
a certain growth rate hits x it's
basically like a screaming buy
opportunity and we look to to deploy
capital well the thing that's tricky
about
i i agree that by historical standards
certainly coinbase now seems cheap the
the hard thing about
valuing a company like coinbase is
obviously it's totally derivative of
what's happening in the crypto world you
use a different computer yeah so if
there's like a crypto crash it's like
well then what's coinbase so but like
sas companies for example these are
strong companies where
you know you look at their amount of
error these are this is these are b2b
subscription businesses
you want to look at their net dollar
attention you know good for a public
company usually starts around 120 so on
january 1st they're typically starting
with 120 of last year's revenue just
from their existing customers
and then they're going to be stacking
new courts on top of that due to new
sales
we think those are very attractive
businesses they also tend to be more
insulated in a recession because they're
b2b not b2c and it's usually the
consumer who gets impacted first in a
recession there's a number of like very
fast-growing public sas companies that
are doing you know a billion-ish
in revenue growing
40 year-over-year
like eighty percent growth seventy
eighty percent gross margins really high
gross margin businesses
these are like fun you know with very
strong franchises big moats at this
point those are i think attractive
companies to own for the long term um
now
you know if you were in one of those
stocks and it's gone down 80 the hard
part is it's gonna take a long time for
them to grow into their old valuations
um
if you can buy now you're obviously the
entry price is much more attractive
for founders same exact problem right so
hey if you went out and you raised money
to 35 times uh multiple workers 100
times or a hundred times yeah whatever
whatever the numbers were a lot of it's
just undisciplined investing some of it
was just hey i felt fomo i have a big
fund i have to deploy the capital uh
what do you do there if you're the
founder who basically has this huge
thing i guess there's kind of two two
components one is like how do you ensure
that your investors end up coming out on
top right and do you just try to grow
into the valuation as quickly as you can
and then two is like how do you take
care of the employees who now maybe
their options are underwater or whatever
on that like how do you kind of
mentor founders in that situation yeah
so here's the good news if you're an
early stage startup is if you're a
public company for example and you're
growing 20 year-over-year and
you your value's gone down 80 because of
this correction
uh you have to basically now grow 5x
what's that like 500
to get back to where you were growing 20
a year like that's going to take you
forever
however let's say that you are a startup
that's tripling year over year and
there's like quite a few of those right
you raise 100 times last year well in
just one year it's going to be about 30
30 times 33 times because you've now
tripled your arr and the year after that
if you triple again you're going to be
at roughly 10 times arr and now you're
starting to look pretty cheap
so
you so it's much easier to grow into
what was perhaps an inflated evaluation
last year as an early stage company
that's roughly tripling or even say
growing two and a half times year over
year what you want to make sure of is
that you give yourself the time
because where you don't want to be is
needing to fundraise every 12 to 18
months like people are doing during the
frothy times you want to be in a
position where you don't have to raise
for two two and a half three years and
now you actually have the time to go
into your evaluation
you won't get as big an upround
as you thought you're going to but
you have the chance if you grow
you know six to 10 times over two year
period to now get an up round
i want to ask you a couple of uh
scenario-based kind of just tactical
things that i've heard founders ask me
or talk about when i've been at dinners
or
kind of gatherings the first is uh if
you want to cut your burn how do you
evaluate uh cost and if you center on
okay i'm gonna have to cut staff like
who do you cut do you cut your high
salaries do you cut the people who you
think are the least productive
do you cut the people you don't like
like you know like what like what is the
tactical way to actually evaluate hey i
have to cut you know i caught my uh head
count by 30 like who do i cut
yeah i think so i think first of all you
have to figure out how much you need to
cut and one thing you need to do is ask
the question am i capable of fundraising
in the current environment because
fundraising right now is very tough but
not impossible if you have great metrics
in the presentation that you mentioned
that we just sort of published
we have a slide that defines what good
looks like what sorry what great looks
like what good looks like and then what
batter we call a danger zone looks like
and what we've said is look if you have
all great metrics there's like five main
ones it's you know it's it's your ar
growth rate and a dollar retention
capital efficiency stuff like that
if it's all great you're gonna be able
to raise i would still be
cautious how you spend but it's not like
you know you're not gonna be able to
raise
if you're merely in the good column
you might have trouble if you're great
on three variables and good on two
you'll probably be able to raise if you
have any danger zone variables you
probably will not be able to raise
so the first thing you have to do is
assess do you have any danger zones do
you really think you're able to raise
and then the question it so let's say
that you
most startups have some problem they
need to fix it could be a gross margin
problem could be an excess burn problem
could be a growth problem but if they're
in the danger zone you you now know that
i'm not going to raise when i run out of
money i'm dead
so i need to be able to make this money
last long enough to fix my problems to
get out of the danger zone and into good
to great metrics
so then the question is well how long do
you need to do that and in my experience
it takes
you know two years
you know minimum really to fix big
problems in a business it's hard right
doing startups is hard and you need to
give yourself the luxury of time to fix
those problems um
the other thing you have to remember is
when you think about how much time you
need
if you give yourself two years runway
you haven't because
you got to go out and fundraise six
months nine months before you run out of
money so if you say i'm i have two years
of runway you've really only given
yourself five maybe six quarters
to make effective changes in the
business
and you know people want to see vc's
want to see that after you've made the
changes that they're working
so you know this is why we say give
yourself two and a half years so you
have two years to work on the business
then you can go fundraise and if you can
give yourself three so much the better
you just don't know what market
conditions are going to be like when and
you don't want your company to go out of
business because of something that's
happening in the macri you know economic
environment
when you think about um
the founder who could raise maybe than
good maybe they're in the great uh
how much of this is like just go get the
money and the economic kind of structure
of the deal is less important than
actually getting the money versus uh you
guys advise founders to still hold on to
you know do good fundraising deals don't
take down rounds and um
kind of what is the weight of importance
between money maybe versus terms of the
deal at this point i think you want to
get the money um you don't mess around
is my view on this um look i
i've always believed that the market
sets the price and um
it's better not to like monkey around
with that don't try and do tricks or
whatever it's like look just run an
efficient process get all of your
materials together go out to enough
firms and then whatever the price is
that's the price i mean
we're all price takers in this market i
mean vc's are price takers too people
always think that somehow when i give
this like bad news that i'm like talking
my books and trying to drive down prices
i don't set the prices you know what
happens is a bunch of different firms
proffer term sheets or not and then you
kind of it shakes out where it shakes
out and then founders hear from other
founders who've gone through a process
recently and they hear oh like prices
aren't 100 times anymore like last year
they're
20 times you know so word gets out the
price levels adjust and so vcs like our
philosophy is we just choose the deals
we want to be in and then we try to pay
the prevailing prices
and you know last year prices were high
this year they're lower but we just paid
the prevailing prices i would urge
founders to have that mentality as well
which is look you're just out there
raising this money because you need this
money
to survive and to grow your business
like
you know making deals with vcs is not
the point of your business
it's just something you do because you
want to fund it so go out there raise
the money you need run a tight process
run a good process and where the
valuation shakes out it shakes out
um and by the way if that means a down
round then so be it i mean look i don't
think there's a
public company on earth no matter how
good amazon tesla
you know microsoft so forth that hasn't
had huge down days in the stock market
it hasn't all been one way up but yet
founders always think that well i've got
to get like a huge up around it's like
sometimes the world doesn't work that
way yeah um a founder calls you says
david how do i run an efficient
fundraising process in this environment
is it get the materials in the data room
go out to 50 firms just set up zooms
back to back to back and you know see
where term sheets come in or is it
something more complicated no i think
that's basically it i mean maybe not 50
maybe start with 10
but yeah like get all of your materials
together
you know it's you know what questions
you're going to get asked you know
what materials you're going to need i
don't understand why founders
have fundraising conversations without
getting all their materials together
first you know as long as they think oh
it's not well i'm just having coffee
with a vc or whatever no it's like look
any conversation with vc is a
fundraising conversation sorry this is
the way it is
so get all your [ __ ] together we're not
getting to know each other
well that matters too but it's but it's
still a fundraising conversation like
there's no point going out and having
those conversations if you don't have
your materials together so get them
together create your data room
um have all the metrics ready
again you know in the sas world is very
obvious what you're going to be asked
and
so if we start stumping you
with questions that like it just shows
you're disorganized so
it's an easy way to put your best foot
forward as a founder is just get all
your stuff together
and then you probably are going to need
to create a longer list
than usual of firms to go talk to
um and you can do it in in waves um
sometimes you'll get some feedback on
the first set of pitches you did and
then you can adjust your deck sometimes
you'll hear the same concern over and
over again you might want to add a slide
to
address it do you tell founders go to
the best firms first or maybe the firms
that they're not
as excited about getting so they get the
feedback and then go to the best firms
um
yeah i think you just want to go to the
list of firms that you think are the
best fit for your business and some of
them are more prestigious names than
others but i wouldn't stress too much
about that in this environment yeah yeah
and you know
just go to the the vcs who've expressed
the most interest in your type of
business
another topic that is become way more
popular than i ever thought it would is
uh founder secondaries and uh one i
guess just like what's your perspective
from the investor seat but also having
built businesses uh when founders should
take secondaries or when it's a red flag
that they're taking secondaries and kind
of how to structure them and then two is
uh founders now who have taken
secondaries have a pot of money and most
founders didn't have a pot of money
before now they do and they're asking
themselves like am i a vc now should i
just go angel invest in all my friends
companies should i just stick in the s p
500 and you know forget about and go
work on my company like how do you
advise founders there yeah so on on
founders taking secondaries um
i think that
it's so the way secondary started you
know way back when is that you would
have a company
that was doing well that maybe got an
acquisition offer
and there's a feeling on the board
especially on the part of vcs that this
company could be much bigger if they
just kept going but the founder had all
their eggs in one basket and would be
very tempted to take this offer
and so creating liquidity for partial
liquidity for a founder was a great way
to align everyone to go for the big long
term win
and so i'm very supportive of that idea
and you know i've been a founder i've
had all my eggs in one basket it's nice
if you can
if you've earned the right to take some
secondary because you've created a great
business
and you want to take a few tips off the
table then go for a bigger win um
is is that like five percent of your
position or like fifty percent like how
do you think that would be way too much
okay you know i think
what i've seen is founders taking a few
percent you know off the table that kind
of idea okay um you know if you see 50
it's like we'll just sell the whole
company i mean that just
um but i think what happened is that in
the boom times you started seeing
secondaries become almost a matter of
course because there was so much funding
that was trying to get into companies
and look i think it became acceptable as
well in an environment in which
companies were potentially over funded
and investors were trying to get to a
certain ownership level that they're
like hey can we buy some secondary from
the founders and i don't really have a
problem with that either but where i
would
you know caution is
in a much more difficult fundraising
environment it's irresponsible for
founders to be seeking to take chips off
the table when that money could be going
into the corporate treasury in other
words into primary in the company and if
there's any concern about the company
not being adequately funded enough and
the founders seeking to put money in
their own pocket that's a conflict of
interest
and you know it's not in keeping with
their duty
of loyalty to the company put the
company first so i think in the current
environment a founder seeking to take
chips off the table would be an
incredibly negative signal and would
probably sabotage your funding round so
i would not do that if somehow you're
one of the few companies in this
environment in which people are
literally throwing more money at you
than you could possibly need
and you and the board decide together
like look this is more money than we
need
then maybe the founder could take trips
off the table but i wouldn't go seeking
to do that in this environment yeah i
think it makes complete sense uh and
then for those who either already have
or are in the fortunate position where
they've built such a great business that
people are throwing money at them uh
what's been your advice to people in
terms of hey you're a founder you now
have a pot of money whether it's a
million dollars or more um you know
bigger sums
put an s p angel invest set it in cash
uh
give it to a fund manager like what do
you say yeah what i would say so i think
typically what makes sense for
a lot of people like founders is to have
kind of a barbell strategy so you've
already got most of your net worth is
tied up in the form of equity in this
highly risky startup you know let's say
over here on the distribution so the
question is what do you do with the rest
of the money and
i think what probably makes sense is to
the barbell is you put that money in the
safest thing possible basically because
you already have so much exposure
to market uncertainty and risk through
the bulk of your net worth which is in
your company
and you want to avoid like
excessive correlation to like let's say
a
like a depression or a recession or
something like that i mean think about
what would happened
let's say that you were a founder who
did a big secondary last year
and you took all that money and you put
it in crypto or you put it in the nasdaq
well now you're down 50 you know
and you already had enough exposure
to start up risk
and sort of macroeconomic risk through
your company so i would i would advocate
for a barbell strategy yeah it makes
sense um one thing i'm always fascinated
by is you've been very successful both
in entrepreneur and investor we actually
have a tweet you tweeted this a while
ago and uh i saw it and then mentally
said to myself if i ever have him on the
podcast i have to ask about this tweet
and it was jeff lewis talking about the
midas list okay and he said uh talk
about keith's boy while he's likely to
be on the mice list this year that
hasn't been on it for the past two to
three years speaks volumes about their
methodology and you followed up and said
i had a pretty good year too eight exits
you name the companies but none of them
count because it was my own money
so i kept 100 percent instead of 20
which they don't like whatever
and
forget the minus list stuff and kind of
debate there for a second uh
those eight companies exiting you're the
individual investor it's your money uh
whatever the math is they were starting
small they ended up being big
how do you manage your own money like
are you just all in startups and that's
like pretty much what you're doing do
you have stocks do you do real estate do
you buy you know local businesses and
david sax's funding you know the the gas
station down the street like what do you
do or what's your approach
so um i mean i generally do it myself
and i mean there's an old saying which
is uh concentrate to get rich diversify
to stay rich so we are all if you're
doing a startup you're highly
concentrated like i'm saying in this
venture
and i think what you want to do is if
you're lucky enough to be successful you
want to diversify so that
you know
you can go down with the market but
you're not a position to lose everything
you know
and so i don't do anything exotic you
know it's the short answer is i'm pretty
diversified
uh and that's like diversification it's
just like you're buying a low cost index
type stuff or are you yeah i mean i try
to yeah i mean i'm not like a huge
public market stock picker i generally
just buy
indices for the most like vanguard funds
type stuff
i do some commercial real estate
investing um probably because you know i
like it it's fun
um but remember you know most of the
investing i do is actually through craft
you know and i also write large gp
checks to craft so i'm doing i'm getting
that exposure already
and so i'm not trying to do anything
like overly aggressive in my own
portfolio because
i'm really just focused on you know
investing the right startups yeah it's
um it's always fascinating to me right
like the amount of risk it takes to
build companies and then to then
basically have to turn that off in terms
of managing the rest uh goes counter to
you know the dna of many of these people
uh and so hearing you you know imagining
you buying low cost indexes and then the
famous story of elon be like well i had
180 million dollars and i basically
spent it all right like it is uh uh very
interesting well part of it is that
it's part of it is time and attention as
well as risk so i want my time and
attention to be where actually hopefully
i have like an advantage as an investor
which is in the startup ecosystem and
it's very time consuming to work with
these companies to be picking all that
kind of stuff i don't want to be
spending my time trying to figure out an
active strategy
you know i'm saying i'm like i don't
want to read the quarterly reports of
all these companies i mean i'm not
saying there's anything wrong with doing
that it's just i personally
don't want to spend the time to do it so
i want to implement easy strategies i'm
imagining you sitting there day trading
from your desk
i've never been never been a day trader
um so yeah i mean
yeah got it um my last question is one
of our sponsors is eight sleep and uh
they've got the thermo-regulated bed um
walk us just through like a day in your
life slash like diet sleep like just how
do you try to optimize your life to be
able to do all the things that you're
doing yeah i'm an investor in a sleep
it's a great product i really like it so
am i yeah so you sleep on one then yeah
yeah yeah yeah i just make it so yeah no
no i think it's great um i love the the
data it gives me on whether i had a good
night's sleep or whatever and then you
can like program the the temperature and
get very precise with that
um so no i like it um
so the question is kind of around
routines yeah just like how do you try
to optimize your day you've got a ton of
stuff going on but you're obviously very
focused on um
investing you also have one of the top
podcasts in the world so you know that
obviously is a huge drain on your time
um just what do you do to optimize to be
happy and get it all done
yeah i mean so my schedule gets kind of
filled up with with meetings and
a lot of it is
responsive in a way it's basically
a portfolio company is having a board
meeting or needs advice or
someone on the team
wants me to take a look at a potential
portfolio company and so
the calendar kind of gets filled up with
that stuff and um
you know when i was a ceo and i was
actually running companies i had a
little bit more control over my own
schedule like i would decide what
i wanted to do what i want to focus on
that day when you're vc it's a little
bit more
reactive because it's other people
whether it's prospective new companies
or portfolio companies are kind of
coming to you
and want to meet and that that's fine
um and so there's a lot a lot of that
stuff and then you know i'll do media
podcasts and so on
um we we only do the all in pod once a
week so it's not a huge amount of time
for me joking but yeah
but yeah so
um
you know and then i tend to be a little
bit of a night owl and i'll stay up late
and like read stuff and catch up on do
you have any weird diets or anything
like that
um
no you know i did i did lose a bunch
well i i gained a lot of weight during
cove like everybody else like the
quarantine 15 or whatever
and then i managed to lose it and so i
did like a modified it wasn't keto diet
but more like mediterranean diet for a
while
and
now it's just more normal but i try to
stay low carb
and then another product that i actually
use uh is one of dave free burke's
products called munique okay which is an
m-u-n-i-q
okay it's basically a powder that you
just pour into water and it becomes like
a shake
you can get different flavors like
chocolate shake
and it's it's uh like a prebiotic fiber
and it keeps your
blood sugar more stable throughout the
day and it reduces your appetite oh
interesting so i found that to be
helpful yeah
um
awesome this has been fantastic where uh
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or if there's founders who
want to uh to talk to craft where's yeah
so yeah contact us to craft ventures um
i'm afraid to give my my email
let's put it this way if you know it
should be easy to get to us
uh you know use your skills to find
someone in our network shouldn't be that
hard and you can reach out to craft
ventures awesome we had somebody come on
they gave their email uh and they said
i'll give i'll mail you a free book and
uh suppose there were six thousand
people that emailed them and they spent
the next week trying to get rid of the
email so please don't do that um i hope
that uh that you guys all joined you can
follow david on twitter at david sacks
but uh this was fantastic i really
enjoyed it and we'll definitely do it
again yeah thanks for having me that's
great